in my 20s I bought a danelectro guitar
kind of a cheap garage guitar and I
learned EAB 7 on it and then I got
interested in other stuff I put it down
and this guy here he's about 16 he picks
it up and starts playing it all the time
in his room and I thought it sounded
pretty good and I thought whoa this is
interesting he's gonna become a rock and
roll star that's what's gonna happen
with his music and my parents were kind
of worried about him you know I'd shut
himself off in the room here and I said
don't worry about him you know he he's
he's got a gift you know it's going to
happen and and then you know his first
movie big movie he gets he gets
nominated for an Academy Award for the
last picture show and there goes his
whole music thing and I and I he always
played as a hobby but I always felt bad
about that and that's why I was so happy
when crazy heart came along that he
could realize that but when when Jeff
did last picture show I was nervous as
his big brother because he's going off
on location with all these other actors
and it was kind of a big production and
I was worried about the social aspect of
it I mean how old were you yeah yeah it
was about 20 so I was kind of worried
about it so I went to this hotel like a
Howard Johnson's or something in some
funky town of Texas and I go up there
and ice there's a few people sitting
around the pool I said you know where
Jeff's room is and they were you know
drinking having a good time was like a
Sunday they said he's up there so I walk
up to the second floor and I'm looking
and I had no idea what number of his
room was or anything and I'm going along
looking for what lead me to knowing if
it's his room and I come to this one
room and there's a big huge portrait
kind of a modern version of Jesus and it
says down there signed love Jay
and I said that's my brother's room and
it was